[Music]
for now you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive uh it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the director of the demos think talk
tank paulie mackenzie and the former
conservative special adviser anita
berting they will be with us from now
until just before midnight uh let's
start with a look at what's on some of
those front pages uh the mirror first of
all carnage and that is its headline it
says storm eunice has left a hundred and
fifty thousand homes without power at
the times that calls it a day of
destruction and it focuses uh on
pressure on energy companies to restore
power to hundreds of thousands of home
homes uh the telegraph meanwhile
pictures the o2 arena after its roof was
shredded uh by the storm it adds that
wind speeds were the highest ever
recorded in england
that is also the lead for the guardian
which focuses on the four people killed
during today's
storm
the express
also has that picture and says the
clear-up bill will amount to around 500
million pounds
the daily star also leading on the roth
of storm eunice which it calls a
122 mile an hour killer
meanwhile the ft focuses on the ongoing
crisis in ukraine it splashes on
vladimir putin's decision
to bring forward nuclear drills as
tensions with kiev escalate
and a different story for the daily mail
which has comments about the head of mi5
about the threat posed to britain by
hostile powers like russia and china
which are accused of targeting mps
and a reminder to you that uh by
scanning the qr code that you'll be
seeing on screen during the program you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you are watching
us uh well let's introduce uh our guests
we're joined tonight by director of
demos think tank uh paulie mackenzie and
the former conservative special advisor
anita boateng let's get right into it
thank you very much so to both of you
for being here uh with us uh on a friday
night um let's start with the mirror and
it's uh front page there which we we
actually just showed uh
previously
one of the stronger headlines carnage so
eunice batters britain anita would you
agree with that assessment carnage
i mean it's felt and definitely taken
quite a lot of people by surprise
wherever they were in the country and
certainly you know they have the
headline figures there from the mirror
three dead 150 000 homes potentially
with no power 500 million pounds cleanup
i mean i'm a councillor in in london and
i've been shocked at the number of trees
for instance that have come down and i
think we're we're almost lucky that more
people haven't lost their lives
absolutely um i wonder given given that
we were uh warned it it feels as though
uh polly we have come a long way from
1987 in the storm that uh people
underestimated well the meteorologists
under underestimated as well
this morning i think there were many of
us waiting and waiting in expectation um
perhaps thinking is is this it and then
of course this afternoon it it uh it
struck
for you i mean these images are
incredible but do you think that how
have you sort of uh i guess assessed the
way that this storm has been trailed and
handled uh and sort of well full seen
predicted
i think you know both the meteorologists
and then lots of public service
providers have in large part handled
themselves very well i was impressed by
uh
some of the train cancellations for
example just giving as much information
as they could sharing pictures so that
people could understand what was
happening updating their advice be being
clear actually with people so that they
could we could take those steps to keep
ourselves safe to you know tie down
things in the garden whatever that might
be
keep away from those trees i mean you
know there's a tree down in my local
park uh anita's talked about the ones
near her it you know
it's i don't i don't remember seeing
trees failed like that actually since
1987 there was a a big tree came down in
our school uh playground and that was
sort of it was there for weeks or at
least to my childhood memory i think it
was there for weeks on end
um and and i think that is really
important that we have been able to
respond in that way but it does remind
us that you know there's not much you
can do in the face of the weather it is
it's frustrating it's expensive
uh and and can just devastate all sorts
of plans 150 000 homes without power my
dad actually is one of them in in rural
wales he'll be out without power for
another 24 hours and
you know for especially for vulnerable
people that can be absolutely
overwhelming uh you know if you're
reliant on medicines that you need to
keep in your fridge for example or
electrical equipment for people with
disabilities so i really hope that the
power companies in particular are
getting support to those vulnerable
people um over the next 24 hours and we
will come back to those people uh
without uh power uh at the moment but
first i want to bring in the times uh
who have a double spread uh on on storm
eunice with some absolutely incredible
pictures uh of the damage caused by uh
the storm uh they lead with three dead
obviously this did not this went to
print before we knew about the fourth
person who had uh been killed uh by the
storm in the uk but some incredible
pictures there of obviously the damage
done to transportation to church the
church spire there and those waves
crashing
um anita do you think enough uh was done
on the on the transport side of things
obviously the trains have been most uh
affected but then we've seen those
incredible images of lorries uh lorry
falling over on the on the road again it
was something that uh was supposed not
to be happening this time around because
it had happened in previous uh storms do
you think the transport uh those in
charge of transport got it right this
time round
well i actually think the messaging has
been very clear and i i suspect that one
of the reasons why we haven't seen as
many fatalities and serious incidents is
because a lot of people just stayed at
home um and decided to avoid kind of
quote unquote avoidable travel i think
um i'm sure that the mirror had a bit of
this story about jet tv um and the
coverage of for instance planes um that
had particularly difficulty landing at
heathrow for various boring and
complicated reasons but essentially um
there were huge huge huge planes that
had to land at heathrow and we had this
incredible scenes today
of um an amateur airline enthusiast
we're you know filming
attempts from various different um
twin-sized jet engine huge planes
attempting to land but generally i think
if you look across the transport system
it hasn't fallen over lots of lots of
instruction was very clear to sort of
stay at home so a lot of cars weren't on
the road and when it comes to trains
lots of trains i think were sensibly
cancelled
i mean i think if there was any silver
lining to this uh to this storm it was
certainly seeing those planes and and
the uh amazing suddenly going viral of
uh of the host of that jet uh program or
that jet channel um let's bring in the
express here with its front page which
shows the o2 the millennium dome uh
battered by killer storm and you can see
the extent of the damage there uh on the
o2 and in fact our very own jonathan
samuels was reporting was was uh
presenting from there this afternoon we
could really see the extent uh of the
damage on uh that building um
polly if we go back to those without
power because interestingly there have
been different numbers in different
publications on how many are without
power
and that is at the end of the day that
is one of the things that is that is
going to be scrutinized the most once we
come out of this storm because we've
been here before and there was an idea
that this wouldn't happen a second time
round and now people are not only
without power but being told that the
restoration of their power may actually
be delayed more
we saw um just a few weeks ago in the
northeast people
being stuck without power for days and
days on end
and i hope certainly at the time the the
power networks and the and the suppliers
were
talking about learning the lessons from
that kind of lengthy interruption
for for this as i say
you can't stop bad weather from
happening but what you can do is have
good backup systems and good response
systems you need to think about
do you know where your vulnerable
customers are because it may be that the
uh you know the the retail energy
companies know but the power networks uh
people actually putting the the lines in
place don't particularly know we have
good ways of getting water to people in
emergencies what are the ways that we
get power to people in emergencies what
are the backup sources of of help how do
you get people to other houses family
members for example who do have power
there's a lot of
emergency support that needs to be done
in these circumstances until you can get
the power back on and i i really hope
that lessons have been learned from from
quite recent experience but i i
you know
i think the reality is we need to invest
more
in that response disaster management
because our expectation has to be
that uh extreme weather events are going
to get more and not less likely so back
into the papers this time on the subject
of the ukraine
crisis
which we've been talking about a lot
obviously over the over the course of
the evening let's start with the
financial times um the headline there
putin blames kiev for escalation and
brings forward nuclear drills um i
wonder uh anita
given that joe biden just came out
saying uh in his in his press conference
jose came out saying he was convinced
that putin does intend to invade
ukraine do you think we are on the brink
of an invasion
of ukraine and what repercussions does
that have for uh nato allies but but for
the uk particularly
i mean the thing that stephanie you've
been flagged today is this risk of a
false flag incident so basically
something that might have um you know be
instigated or orchestrated by russia in
order to provide a pretext for action i
think it's clear that this is becoming
incredibly serious and i think the risk
of actual conflict is increasing day by
day and i think fundamentally
what does putin want he wants division
in europe and i think that's why we're
seeing across the papers today that
warning from boris johnson for unity in
europe and that i think is the major
thing that's at risk if russia does
decide to act
notwithstanding the fact that a
sovereign democratic nation would in
that instance be invaded in europe yeah
absolutely we're talking about that that
uh headline that's the telegraph uh pm
calls for unity over heavy sanctions on
russia if if it invades uh paulie do you
think uh it's too little too late has
the west not been united enough quickly
enough
i don't think it's ever too late um but
the reality is that
faced by russian aggression in ukraine
before when they took over annexed
crimea when russians played such a
devastating part in the war in syria
including potentially in chemical
attacks
the the west sort of basically shrugged
its shoulders and have reinforced the
view of president putin that in the end
democracies are a weak form of
government that's not capable of
standing up to his great ambition which
is to
return the eastern bloc to russian
dominance and russian control ideally to
create that greater
it comes up with pretexts you know we
shouldn't believe any of his propaganda
okay polly i'm going to have to cut you
off because we do have i'm so sorry we
do have to try and get to the weather
because it is obviously
an important weather thank you very much
polly and anita we will be back with
them shortly